PROFESSOR: Now,
the standard thing
you do with a recursive
data type in programming
is you define recursive
procedures on them,
so let's look at how that works.
I'm going to define a function
f on a recursively defined data
type R, and the
way I'm going to do
it is I'm going to define f
of b explicitly in terms of b
and operations that are already
understood for all of the base
cases of b in R.
And then I'm going
to define f of a
constructor applied
to x in terms of x and f of x.
And if I keep to
that structure, that
gives me a recursive
definition of the function
f on the recursively
defined data set R.
Let's look at an example
to make this recipe
explicit and clearer.
Let's think about a
recursive function
on a set of matched brackets.
This is a somewhat
interesting one.
Let's define the depth
of a string as follows,
and the idea is it's how deeply
nested are the successive pairs
of left and right brackets.
Well, the depth of
the empty string is 0.
You got to start somewhere,
and it's got no brackets,
we'll call it depth 0.
Now, what about the depth of
the constructor putting brackets
around s and then
following it by t?
Well, putting brackets
around s gives you
a string that's 1
deeper than s is,
and then you follow it by
t, and it's as deep as t is.
So the result is that the
depth of the constructor
is a string which
is a number which
is equal to 1 plus the depth
of s and the depth of t,
whichever is larger.
The max of 1 plus depth of
s and depth of t, and that's
our recursive
definition of depth.
Let's look at maybe another
even more familiar example
of recursive definition.
Let's define the nth power of
an integer or real number k.
The zeroth power k
is defined to be 1,
and the n plus
first power of k is
defined to be k times
the nth power of k,
and this would be an
executable definition
of the exponentiation function
in a lot of programming
languages.
And my point here is that
this familiar definition,
recursive definition on
a nonnegative integer n,
is in fact a structural
induction using the fact
that the nonnegative integers
can be defined recursively
as follows.
0 is a nonnegative integer, and
if n is a nonnegative integer,
then n plus 1 is a
nonnegative integer.
So to summarize, the recipe for
a recursive function definition
is you define f going from
the recursive data type
to values-- whatever
kind of values
you want to assign to
these recursive data--
f of b is defined directly
for the base case b,
of base cases b, and f
of the constructor of x
is defined using f of x and x.
Now, once you've gotten a
function defined recursively,
you can start proving
things about it
by structural induction
or by induction
on its own definition, its
own recursive definition.
So let's look at
an example of that.
I want to prove the
following property
of the depth of
strings in M, namely
that if I look at the length
of a string r plus 2--
so the vertical bars around
r mean the number of brackets
in the string r plus 2 is
less than or equal to 2
to the power of depth
plus 1-- twice the 2 to
of the depth of the string.
And I want to prove that
this holds for all strings
r of matched brackets,
and I'm going to prove it
by structural induction.
And just as a
walk-through, here's
how the proof is going to go.
Let's suppose that
r is the base case.
Is it the case that
this inequality
holds for the empty string?
Well, the length of r is 0, so
length of r plus 2 is 0 plus 2,
or 2, which is the
same as 2 to the 0
plus 1, which is in fact
equal to 2 to the depth
of the empty string plus 1.
So this inequality
actually holds
as an equality in the base
case, and we're good there.
What we next need to show
is that this inequality
holds in the constructor case.
So we're looking at
an arbitrary string
r that's built out of s and
t, and r is left bracket,
s right bracket, t, and
I want to show that r
satisfies this inequality.
Well, by induction
hypothesis, I can
assume that s and t
satisfy the inequality.
So I have that the length
of s plus 2 is at most 2
to the depth of s plus 1 and the
length of t plus 2 is at most 2
to the depth of t
plus 1, and let's just
walk through the proof.
You can slow this down
and replay it if need be,
so I'm just going to
go through it quickly.
The length of r plus 2--
r is, after all, brackets
s, t, so it's simply the
length of that string plus 2
by the definition of r.
The length of brackets
s, t is the length of t
plus the length of s plus
the 2 for the 2 brackets
that we've added, and
so we're plugging that
into the previous term
and getting that plus 2.
Then just rearrange the terms.
It's the same as
the size of s plus 2
plus the size of t plus 2.
And I arranged it that
way because by induction
hypothesis, I know that the
size of s plus 2 is less than
or equal to 2 to the depth of
s plus 1, and likewise for t.
Now I just play a nice
trick to get these 2
exponents to look alike.
I say that the depth
of s is less than
or equal to the max of the
depth of s and the depth of t,
and likewise for the depth of t.
So in both of those terms here,
I can replace the exponent
or replace the depth of s
by the max of depth s and t,
and likewise here.
Now I've got the
same term twice,
so I can say that it's
simply twice the max depth.
And of course, that is
equal to, by definition
of the depth of r, twice
2 to the depth of r,
which is of course 2 to
the depth of r plus 1.
And I have by more or less
automatically plugging
into the definitions and
a structural induction,
I've proved that
this inequality holds
for the recursively defined
depth function, and we're done.
Let's look at one
more familiar example.
I want to give [? the ?]
recursive definition
of the positive powers of 2.
So the base case is the 2
is a positive power of 2,
and the constructor is
just one constructor
I'm going to use-- that if x
and y are positive powers of 2,
then their product is
a positive power of 2.
So let's look at some examples.
I can start with 2 and
then the only thing
I can do as a constructor
is multiply 2 by 2 to get 4.
Once I got 4, I can
do 4 times 2 to get 8,
and I can do 4
times 4 to get 16,
and I can do 4 times 8 to
get 32, and all of these
are positive powers of 2.
Now let's define the log to the
base 2 of a positive power of 2
recursively.
Well, the log to the
base 2 of 2 is 1.
I'd have to define log to
the base 2 in the base case,
and that's easy to do.
What about in the
constructor case?
Well, the log to the base 2
of x, y is equal to the log
to the base 2 of x plus
the log to the base
2 of y for all the x, y's
that are positive powers of 2,
and so I have defined a
log of the constructor x,
y in terms of the function
log of x and the function log
applied to y.
It conforms to the
standard definition
of a recursive function on
a recursively defined data
type, [INAUDIBLE]
positive powers of 2.
Now, this looks OK.
Well, let's just check it out.
So log of 4 is log
of 2 times 2, which
is by the definition of the
log of 2 plus the log of 2,
which is 1 plus 1, which is
equal to 2, and guess what?
That's correct.
The log of 8--
well, 8 is 2 times
4, so by the recursive
definition, that's the log of 2
plus the log of 4, which we
previously figured out log of 4
was 2, so we get 3 and the
answer comes out right.
Now, remember, you're not
supposed to in this reasoning
use the properties that you
know that log to the base 2
has because we're defining
this function which we're
calling log to the base
2 and implicitly claiming
that it's right.
But in order to prove
that it's right,
we need to be using just see
the structural definition of log
to the base 2 to
prove its properties.
So that was what
I was illustrating
with this reasoning, that just
plugging in the constructor
case of log of x, y is
log of x plus log of y,
I can get these numbers out.
So the point of this is just to
make the following definition
look reasonable.
I'm going to define
a new function which
I'm going to call
the log e function,
and it's another function
on the positive powers of 2,
and here's the definition
of the log e function.
The log e of 2 is going to
be 1, just as the log is,
but the log e of x, y is
going to be x plus the log
e of y for all x, y and
positive powers of 2.
Well, let's try that definition.
Log e of 4 is log e
of 2 times 2, which
according to the recursive
definition is 2 plus the log
e of 2, which is
1-- namely, it's 3.
Log e of 8-- well, 8 is 2
times 4, so the log e of 8
is 2 plus the log e of 4.
We just figured out that
the log e of 4 was 3,
so it's 2 plus 3 is 5.
Log e of 8 is 5.
And finally, log e of 16--
well, 16 is 8 times 2,
so the log e of 8 times
2 is 8 plus the log
e of 2, which we know is 1.
It's 9.
So we've just figured out the
log e of 16 is 9, but now comes
the problem.
16, of course, is not only 8
times 2, but it's 2 times 8,
and so the log e of 2 times
8 is 2 plus the log e of 8.
Log e of 8 we previously figured
out was 5, so the log e of 16
is 7, and now I have
an inconsistency.
I have used this recursive
definition of log
e to conclude that the log
e of 16 is both 9 and 7,
and we got a problem.
It's not a good
definition of a function.
The problem is a simple
one called ambiguity.
There's more than
one way to construct
the elements of PP2, of
positive powers of 2,
from the constructor x times y.
16 was 8 times 2, but
it's also 2 times 8,
and of course, it's
also 4 times 4.
And depending on
which constructor
you use to construct
16, you're going
to get out different values
assigned to the log e function.
So when you have an ambiguously
defined recursive data
structure-- for example
F18 is very ambiguous--
then defining recursive
functions on that definition
is not going to
work well, and you
have to very carefully prove
that a recursive definition
actually works in
a single value.
So for example, log to
the base 2 does work,
but that would require
proof it doesn't follow on
general principles [INAUDIBLE]
you define a recursive function
on an ambiguous data type.
On the other hand,
the reason why
we chose that somewhat
unexpected single constructor
for the balanced strings M,
the balanced bracket strings,
was that it turns out
to be unambiguous.
And so that definition of
depth is a good definition,
as is any definition based
on the recursive definition
of the set M.
So the general problem we
have to watch out for--
[AUDIO OUT]
Constructor created the datum e.
If there's more than
one way to construct e,
then you're not
quite sure which case
to use to define the
function f, and that's
why this issue of whether or not
the data structure's ambiguous
is critical to getting
good definitions
of recursive functions.